we are back with a guest who actually
it's funny I'm a big fan of some of the
stuff she's she's written and she's done
we certainly don't agree on a lot but on
something she's incredibly informative
and I'm really glad to have her on
author of the vegetarian myth right off
the bat we're bound to get some letters
lyric e thank you so much for being on
with us oh well thanks for having me
Steven well good so listen this book
I've been reading for a while now I'll
be honest you know I'm probably at about
2/3 about 2/3 of the way through you
make some first offer the audience who
might not be familiar with you why don't
you tell them your story as to how you
came about writing this book so I spent
20 years as a vegan I became a vegan
when I was 16 the way that most people
become vegans which is I had a friend
who was a vegan and she and her family
were really into being vegan and within
two weeks of knowing her I was
completely convinced that I had to do
this and I was one of those people who
did not give up most people actually who
try it give up in three months that's
what the studies show and I did not give
up for 20 years and in the process it
completely destroyed my health it was
just an utter collapse so when that
happens especially when you have clung
to an ideology that strongly it's really
hard it's you know your whole world sort
of collapses around you because nothing
makes sense anymore and you don't even
know who you are anymore at that point
so I spent a good four or five years
after that trying to figure out what had
I done wrong because I hadn't done the
diet wrong so why did this go so wrong
so I had to look at a whole bunch
information that I had shuttled aside
right in service of this ideology and
then a whole just a huge realm of
information was then open to me there
were all kinds of things I could explore
but it was a very good I would just case
it's crazy because listen it's no secret
with my with people listening here
whether online or terrestrially that I I
have a I have a passionate disdain for
veganism but sometimes for different
reasons I mean let's be let's be clear
you were a little bit nervous about
coming on the show because obviously I'm
one of those right-wing kind of nut jobs
you are certainly not by any means a
right winger as you write this book
again
veganism no I mean I come at this from a
very sympathetic perspective I was in
that world I understand the values of
that world and I don't intend to give up
the values of that world and this is why
the vegans hate me is because I still
claim the same moral ground I won't give
it up and they're really mad that I
could come to different conclusions and
this is where you bump into the
fundamentalism you know yeah of any
ideology that gets you cling so tightly
that it becomes wrong
yeah if it starts out in a good
direction it ends you can't hang on to
anything that tightly have it turned out
okay well you know I I really hate that
and this is kind of where we can find
some some common ground I hate this idea
that if you eat animals you hate animals
I mean we have a dog ma he's actually
sitting right here will bring up the
hopper cam for people watching online
who you know we adopted a 90-pound looks
like the world's biggest meanest pit
bull who was balding he had alopecia
broken leg Lyme disease because we love
it we're animal lovers but I don't see
it as something that is unnatural or
goes against nature or in any way
displays hatred because of the way we
are designed as human beings you talk
about that a lot in your book tell me a
bit about that and as someone who is
really more of an environmentalist and
more of an animal rights person how you
sort of rectify that so I have a 90
pound dog - oh there you go what kind of
dog I have a great pyrenees oh well you
know what this is a dog or argentino and
if you're familiar with the breed yeah
yeah yeah great pyrenees is part of that
it gives them the big square head so
yeah no I mean I got my dog for
protection so I'm really she's fabulous
anyway I put her outside wait protection
from rabies
yeah well yeah I get a lot of yeah
they're not gonna be able to follow
through listen they're too exhausted and
they're not necessarily pro-second
amendment people I mean I tell everyone
listen I don't even I don't even invest
in alarm system I have shotguns out the
wazoo and a 90 pound dog but you know I
get definite tonight
that's my alarm system I want them to
see that and I have a dog and I have a
permit to carry so there's only somebody
yes now I'm a big believer in the Second
Amendment as well I think people have a
right to defend themselves and
especially when you live under this kind
of you know just constant harassment
there's a point passed which you just
have to take it seriously
Jim
so they're crazy people absolutely I was
telling you about the last comments I
got on YouTube right before I came on I
can't even repeat it on air yeah very
anti-semitic very you know homophobic
even though I'm not Jewish or gay but
that doesn't matter it doesn't stick
that's what they want is just to hurt
you and I've heard the most horrible
things about you to the point that
honestly when I first heard about you I
felt like oh this is this is a this has
got to be like a right wing Sarah Palin
hunting wolves kind of chick who the
vegans are just furious with that's not
the case at all out of this fashion
occur and do you think that even makes
them more mad because it's kind of like
a Muslim convert who needs to be
executed I'm an apostate yeah that's
smart that's exactly it
so yeah alright so you had this other
question of a real question than it was
about environmentalism so the thing that
I did not know when I was 16 there's two
parts to this one is that agriculture is
the most destructive thing that people
have done to the planet and I can walk
you through that if you want to hear
about it so I thought that I was eating
this peaceful loving sustainable you
know totally compassionate diet and it's
not true it is the most destructive
human activity and those were the foods
I was eating and as somehow thinking it
was peaceful and compassionate it's not
it's biotic cleansing is what it is and
you know we've wiped out 98% of the
old-growth forests and somewhere around
ninety percent of the world's prairies
have been destroyed mostly in the
surface of Agriculture so for anyone to
say that you know wiping out the massive
amounts of habitat for every living
creature that needs a home there's
nothing that's environmentally sound
about this in fact I've got all kinds of
wonderful quotes from you know very
serious people about the fact that this
cannot be done sustainably that it's an
absolute oxymoron to call to call
anything sustainable agriculture the
only thing that sustains us
petrochemicals plows and fences and
subsidies federal subsidies yeah that's
you know the whole system going at this
point and there's so there's nothing
environmental about this it's been sold
to us as the way to eat green and
nothing could be further from the truth
now the part where we can disagree is
about factory farming because I think
everybody can say that hey these are
these poor creatures are just living
horrible lives and and be it is
absolutely just a total waste of
everybody's energy
you know just count from calories on up
to feed bizarre things to animals that
were not designed to eat them and it is
very energy-intensive cows are not
designed to eat corn they should not be
eating corn it kills them
it makes us unhealthy when we eat I hate
to cut you off but I want you to hold
that thought because I'm with you here a
lot it was crowded we'll be right back
after the break we are back with who I
think is a fascinating guest Lear Keith
who was talking right now just about
factory farming so to be fair a lot of
problems with the other things that you
said but I agree with you and the
federal subsidies and the factory
farming listen I'm I and it's also a
piece listen I just wrote a piece in the
blaze magazine that went up this week
the scam of the FDA and USDA or first
off supplements it was an
all-encompassing piece but also the
organic food scam it's complete I
actually went down and I buy locally
from farms now I buy lamb I buy eggs and
they will never be certified organic
because they can't afford it the
subsidized mega farms can afford the
right fence posts or you know they use
the right chemicals even though there's
plenty of pesticides and chemical
fertilizers that are used in organic
food so what tell us a bit about about
that and the sort of the shell game that
is factory farming and why people of all
political walks should know about it
okay so back in way at 1950 factory
farming is invented because they took
all the ammunition plants from World War
two and they converted them to nitrogen
fertilizer since that point we've been
eating well okay that's what the entire
thing is based on and what that created
was a mountain of corn just a vast
amount of corn there was no way to sell
that much corn to eat that much corn
what were they gonna do with all that
corn and the answer was hey let's put
animals in really hellacious conditions
and essentially make them live in cities
on concrete floors inside steel
buildings and will force-feed them corn
and make them get really fat really fast
which makes the meat cheap but it also
makes the animals really sick and it
makes us really sick this is not the
meat we were designed to eat right and
it's not the native diet of a cow and
the only reason this is possible is
because of the farm bill every year that
subsidizes the growing of that corn then
what is that all of these pork farmers
are essentially serfs to the giant the
six corporations that control the world
food supply so they're you know hand in
glove and though and that's our tax
dollars are going to pay for this stuff
and by making those subsidies every year
on things like corn and wheat and soy
it means the cheapest calories out there
are this crap carbohydrate and that's
why America's got fat especially poor
people because it's all they can afford
a couple the only reason they can afford
it is because that's what subsidized
we're not subsidizing the real food
we're not subsidizing farmers we're
subsidizing corn but scrum with fossil
fuel well there are so many P and there
are so many points there to even get her
to firstly I will tell you that half the
world's corn supply is consumed by
French Canadians when they have a big
corn roast literally all it is is bowls
of corn you roll it in a stick of butter
and put salt on it and people eat
literally 20 years of corn each it's a
cultural thing but you know you're right
and it's funny because I know you would
obviously align yourself more to the
left
but then someone like myself but I
couldn't be more against subsidies for
farmers I hate it when politicians on
either side and of course what they do
is they do in other guys of oh we have
to help the American farmer the poor
little American farmer you know weather
is so volatile and seasons change and
they don't know their crops aren't so
consistent we have to subsidize them
because we have to save the American
farmer and that's not the case whether
you're a vegetarian a vegan or liberal
or conservative I think it's a point
that's missed on a lot of people just
like with banks the Federal Reserve when
you pick winners and losers in any
industry in all ways and it's a
centralized power from the federal
government it always favors the big guys
and in this case like you're talking
about in the United States it favors the
big farms who can afford the lobbyists
who can manipulate policy and you've
talked about that in your book and
that's something that I can completely
agree with in I'm on board with so you
know and the other environmental problem
of course is that none of this is
ultimately sustainable you know every
single civilization that's ever sprung
up around AG around agriculture it's the
basis of civilization as agriculture
collapses and it's because it where's at
the topsoil you can't clear all the life
off the land plan it to nothing but what
humans are going to eat and expect that
to last so civilizations last between
800 and 2,000 years and then they
collapse because that's the exact point
when the soil gives out I mean you can
predict it's been eight hundred and two
thousand years the soil will not last
longer than that and you know they died
essentially eating each other you find
human
remains in the cooking pots and that's
the end of it you know it just returns
to dust because this is activity cannot
be sustained that's the problem so
basically if we go vegan fast-forward a
couple hundred years we're Lord of the
Flies smack and chubby little piggy
first glasses to create a fire we are
that's a very bad place to end up let me
ask you this so you consider yourself I
don't want to misrepresent you but you
consider yourself an environmentalist so
pro Second Amendment good promy good now
you talk about these problems as far as
environmental sustainability so let's go
with that premise I have some some
problems with it but let's go with a bit
for time here's my main issue having
been to the the climate summits
Copenhagen Cancun watch the speeches
from Ted Turner do environmentalists see
let me just ask you do you do you see an
irony in obviously condemning big
government in their cozy relationship
with big business completely on board
but then a lot of the solutions that are
offered by people that tend to involve
the government or needing some sort of
government policy if we can't trust them
right now with our food supply if we
can't trust them right now to enact
sensible food policy why would we
entrust them to you know save the planet
well I think the only way we ever get a
government that works is by just
constant pressure applied constantly
it's you know you can never be not
vigilant in the case of people in power
and so I don't think we can ever give up
it's not like oh here fix this for us
it's just mean it means constant
struggle again so that was in power to
try to get them to do something right
and I think that at this point the
problems are so gigantic and so systemic
that we need every solution anybody can
think of to try to turn this around
before it's too late but do you really
think that solution can come from the
government or even if we bring it to the
government that they wouldn't screw it
up I mean that's that's my endgame
listen I think we all want a cleaner
earth and I just certainly want to get
off into the areas that we disagree too
much but I'll just leave it at that it's
one of those things where I do not trust
the government with something as mammoth
as saving the planet if I can't trust
them with a checking account I don't
know why I would trust them with the
ozone layer but back to the meat thing
so you know it's funny I've got a
personal story with that I got convinced
to do the green smoothie thing for a
while and you know a good friend of mine
actually is Rob wolf you'll be on the
cast radio show it's great yeah a few
weeks from now and he's just like
hardcore libertarian so I'm kind of
between you and him but he was one of
the first guys said like oh yeah you
should you should stop doing that right
and we see it everywhere right now you
know green smoothie blog.com well I also
happen to have hypothyroidism which is
very rare for a young
oh yeah it's your unusual for a man
exactly usually usually pre-diabetes
it's a sign of that and my doctor said
well yeah you know if you're doing all
the raw spinach and the kale which we've
all been told is the best thing for you
as much as you can stuff in a blender
it's it's not tell us just if only to
save one thyroid gland out there why the
whole green smoothie green juice thing
might not be as good for you as you
think yeah a lot of those vegetables are
really hard on your thyroid they just
are they're great chickens and they're
gonna do damage really hard on your
thyroid to deal with all the compounds
that are in those vegetables a lot of
vegetables are not particularly edible
until you cook them first of all right
you know a lot of people want you to
believe a lot of those sort of vegan raw
vegan people oh I think cook it it's bad
it's like it's not actually edible so
you apply heat because you have to
destroy what are called anti nutrients
right and in turn you see reinsert
that's one of the ways that think plants
fight back plants don't really want to
be eaten either they can't run and they
don't have teeth in claws like animals
so their only defense are chemicals and
they are the original chemical warfare
people they know how to make chemicals
that can hurt you and that can protect
themselves and protect their babies
essentially so seeds are really hard to
eat you have to do all kinds of things
to trick them to make them edible and
most of the plant as well it doesn't
want to be eaten that's why it tastes
bitter that's why it's poisonous I mean
weak and we have no way to digest
cellulose anyway as humans I mean you
need multiple chambers in your stomach
tons of bacteria that can do the work
like a cow can do that we can't even do
it so most of the plant matter on this
on this planet is never gonna be food
for us but even the things we can sort
of semi digest tend to be a lot more
edible when heat is applied right those
nutrients are destroyed is it's and it's
one of those things it is just one of
those things that nobody believes in you
tell them like I heard I heard the raw
food diet you know cuz Andy Dick's doing
it I'm going ant does Andy dick look
healthy
you you should Mohawk literally I'm he
was on Conan going I'm doing the raw
food diet I'm like well I'm gonna avoid
that that's actually what spurred me to
look into why I thought maybe the green
smoothies were bad and and Rob educated
me and now you know it's funny I do a
lot of raw egg yolks and I do the
fermented cod liver oil and yeah some
things are very edible raw some things
are not raw organ meats you should eat a
little those every week too I know
you're very gross out in this culture by
this but around the world across human
history those are the foods that are
considered sacred and it's for a reason
you know some of the nutrients are
destroyed when they're heated and so raw
liver you know rock kidney raw heart a
little bit every week goes a long way
yeah it's it's a it's amazing to hear
you say this obviously knowing your
history so you're you were vegan right
and then you go into this and you're not
just by the way you're not just no
longer vegan for those tuning in right
now we have Lee our Keith with us who
was a former vegan wrote the vegetarian
myth great book you're you're doing like
bone broth and Oregon meat you know
they're just picturing you like 28 days
later carving into a carcass so a pretty
pretty big 180 yeah what do you say to
someone who might argue obviously vegan
like you said is ideological extremism
and now you've kind of gone the other
way do you think that maybe people who
do what you do either have a fascination
with sort of self-experimentation or
more extreme personalities because it's
pretty I mean it's pretty drastic change
yeah you know it took me five or six
years to come around to all of it okay
so I went really slowly I think you know
when you're young you tend to be more
idealistic and the world is more black
and white and I like to think that I've
learned from my mistake especially after
the permanent damage that I did to my
body I moved very slowly now when I make
a change in my diet and I really
investigate it you know I do a lot of
research and not just on flights that
agree with me but all over and I've
tried to make myself scientific just to
be literate in a scientific way I don't
have a background in science but you
have to be able to read studies and
understand what's going on and that's
not an easy thing we don't get good
science education in this country and
now with the internet you know you can
just stick to your little Bowl find
people who agree with you and never get
challenged and that it presents its own
problems so I try to be very careful
as I you know have shifted my diet over
the last few years but everything that
I've done makes sense to me it's you
know it makes sense from you know just
historical just look at that you know
the scope of human history 2.5 million
years and there's no question to
archaeologists what we ate there's no
question
I don't think people who come up with
these just those stories are people who
are very ideologically driven everybody
else agrees and the evidence is just
overwhelming you know you can see there
you know in the bones and the teeth of
the skeletons you can see that these
people ate mostly meat you see the tools
that they left behind you see the
pictures they drew about it
and then their camp sites are filled
with these remains and there's just no
question what we ate and you can also
look at contemporary hunter-gatherers
there are still 46 tribes remaining of
hunter-gatherers and we know what they
eat right so there's no question at all
and then you just look at you know how
our teeth our jaw all we did with one
stone really quickly I just wanna
because I know a question that a lot of
people will have there and I think I
know the answer if you look at tribes
hunter-gatherers obviously their life
expectancy is significantly shorter how
would you explain that to people who
would just look at those numbers in a
sheet in an explained context yeah the
number that you actually need and this
is gonna get technical is the mortality
rate doubling time and what that does is
it factors out all the environmental
reasons that people die at very young
ages so throughout most of human history
if you live to be five years old you
actually live to be about as old as we
are now but the early childhood was a
hard time to be a human being right and
so you have to factor that out and say
okay so if you got over all the
environmental factors that made being a
baby really hard in prehistory in fact
past that you had really really good
solid health that changed when people
take up agriculture their health
declines rapidly it was actually a
complete disaster for human health when
people switch from these nutrient-dense
diets based on animals to diets based
strictly on carbohydrate and the
archaeological record could not be
clearer their bones just crumble their
teeth fall out and they shrink six
inches it's sounding like national
treasure eighteen Nick Cage is gonna
show up because he has to pay his taxes
let's keep you on for one more segment
because I'm fascinated there Keith stay
tuned we're back a ladder with Crowder
I see this is the thing where I am
fascinated with these guests and I know
we do mainly politics in the show though
we'll have professional athletes or
actors but Lee our Keith wrote this book
the vegetarian myth which the way I
found her was I thought that she was
somebody very different than who she
turns out to be who she turns out to be
is very interesting leered thanks so
much for being back with us so you were
just talking about how catastrophic you
know agriculture can be the human health
and listen I'm a moderate okay I tend to
believe that you know mainly meats and
then some veggies and fruit and I don't
think oatmeal is gonna kill you but I
can understand the argument for sort of
the paleo crowd but I do think like it's
undeniable that a lot of this like a lot
of things is influenced through pull
through those in political power or
those who can you know we those who have
the most amount of cash let's be honest
you were talking about super farms
earlier so that's a big influence I mean
it is accelerated right now if you look
at the American diet and the food
pyramid its human diets have changed at
a rate really would you say it's fair
for me to say in the last hundred years
more than they did in the thousands of
years preceding it yes absolutely and in
the last generation most of all and it's
exactly because of those government
recommendations and the way that they
put those policies forward and changed
the way everybody ate and it was a huge
experiment on public health and it
didn't happen without protest there were
many many doctors who came forward and
said you cannot do this to the American
people
mm-hmm there's no evidence that this is
gonna help we have plenty of evidence
that it might not and the government did
it anyway and now everybody is sick and
fat and stupid and dying and all of
these diseases have absolutely exploded
they've got diabetes now and children
under 10 they can't call it adult-onset
anymore yes so children have it is
horrible what I mean it's just hard well
they told everybody to stop eating fat
and concentrate on eating grains and
that's what happened they switched from
fat and protein to eating a diving of
carbohydrate and we were not designed to
eat a diet that's essentially sugar
right so everybody got sick well what
about people like Rob wolf out there
some Palio's who say you know tubers and
root vegetables things like potatoes
sweet potatoes for high-performing
athletes it's actually better to have a
higher
have a hydrate intake provided they're
not coming from processed grains would
you say that's a that argument holds
water or are they off base I would agree
and I'd but I do think it depends on you
know how much damage you personally have
done to your insulin receptors I did a
lot of damage to mine I cannot tolerate
that load of carbohydrate on a daily
basis so I have to be really careful I
eat a lot of cinnamon it's supposed to
be good for you because I read it once
and I think I'm a doctor you know it's
it's funny how quickly its accelerated
in and here's one thing I like I said I
don't agree with you on everything that
you've brought forward but I do hate
when people on the other side just make
simplistic arguments like well life
expectancies a lot longer well you know
people used to have 19 kids because 12
of them would get kicked by horses the
difference is now they're being taken
out by a few box of fruit loops so the
cause of death is very different and and
obviously there were acute I guess you
can say environmental reasons is the
term you used earlier or acute causes of
death were much more common right but
nowadays the chronic disease is
definitely a problem that I think
everyone kind of acknowledges just
everyone tries to solve it a different
way and the misinformation out there I
want to get back to your book the
vegetarian myth because you do realize
that you are considered like you said in
apostate but not only by vegans but by
general mainstream health right now you
know you should be going to a Jamba
Juice and getting getting a smoothie you
should be you know a majority of your
plate should be salad and fruits how
does that make you feel when you know
what you've done to your body you know
the research you've put into it and for
some reason a majority of the country is
just flat-out wrong
well you know a lot more doctors are
coming around this is pretty much every
day in the news you can find ok another
study that shows gosh that's rated fat
actually doesn't hurt people
right we're wrong it was even on the
cover of Time you know where they're
like oops butter isn't bad you know and
it's it's coming Brown because they did
try this terrible experiment on us all
and it failed so you know they're having
to retrench and I don't know how long
it's gonna take for the really big
institutions like the USDA to kerma the
thing to know about the USDA is that
they are not charged with protecting
public health they are charged with
selling commodity agriculture so they're
gonna keep pushing that food pyramid and
basically until they're dead right
because that's what's the most
for those giant corporations so follow
the money let's always remember that one
- this is zero I often talk about that
and that's where I don't know if you
want to get into disagreements we don't
have to but that's where I have a
disagreement you everyone points to the
Koch brothers or Big Oil and if you look
at where the actual money comes in from
in politics obviously like you said
these subsidies for farms are a big one
but some shocking numbers that it's you
know we've been told it's always big oil
and big pharma and that's not always the
case a lot of people don't think big
farms although they're connections are
obviously still to big oil and ethanol
with with with corn blog people don't
take big unions 15 out of the top 20
donors or big unions namely public
sector unions
so I've railed on that for a long time
if you follow the money trail and you
know how you solve the money trail and
this is where you can tell me if you
think I'm out of line you solve the
money trail by eliminating the crony
capitalism the relationship between
government and big companies I always
say everyone plays identity politics or
the party of small business we're the
party of big business the same thing
applies to food and farming I'm not a
guy who's a small business guy or a big
business guy I'm an honest business guy
and if you're running an honest business
you don't need the government to step in
with my tax dollars to funnel it to you
right and especially with the big banks
yeah no you're right we'll listen to
West Indies the West Indies trading
company I always talk about this
employed a fifth of population earth
they were making over 20 percent on
their dividends and they went bankrupt
and that's one thing to remember when
people coming out saying and this is see
this is we're learning about each other
later we're finding common ground
everyone said the occupiers are correct
they're the first people to do this I
was and I'm not a tea partier I was at
the first Tea Party rally and you know
you may disagree with em in a lot the
biggest signs they had from the get-go
were down with Wall Street in no more
big banks no more bailouts so this idea
that there's you know that leftists are
the only ones against big banks and I
don't know a single conservative not one
not one who was a fan of the Federal
Reserve or big big bank bailouts it's
one of those things I feel like it's
been pushed for some reason just this
false political narrative and I think
it's maybe I don't know why people would
want to malign one world view as being
with big banks when it's not the case
but we agree on that I think pretty much
everyone in the country agrees we need
to do away with big banks yeah
that was Turan it was completely
irrelevant had nothing to do with meat
so let's go fact one thing I find very
interesting that you talk about and I
don't think you claim it as original but
you do articulate it I think in a way
that is better than most people so you
talk about animals and the domestication
of animals and you made a good point I
have it written down in my book here I
don't have the exact quote but you talk
about how people say you know animals
weren't designed to be this way and you
use an example of I think it's 10
million domesticated dogs versus maybe
it's 50 million domesticated dogs versus
10,000 wild wolves and how you know it's
it's sort of funny that we don't see
that as evolution from an animal
perspective these dogs have evolved to
make themselves useful to human beings
and they live longer healthier lives so
this is an idea that domestication of
animals is inherently against some
animal moral code could be backwards am
i miss am i miss quoting it but i know
the actual numbers but i thought the
point was fascinating yeah and you can
say the same things about plants that
most plants don't want much to do with
us but there's a few that figured you
know if we work together it's gonna go
better for both of us and it's true
we've carried them all over the world
we've essentially conquered you know the
forests supplant the annual grasses that
you know we're willing to be
domesticated so in the service of corn
and soy and wheat we've pretty well
conquered the planet so that was very
successful for corn and soy and wheat
most grasses aren't willing to do that
they're not willing to change their
genome enough to make themselves
interesting to us but some plants have
been you could look at the potato it's
the same thing Michael Pollan talks
about the apple you know like wild
apples are basically inedible but they
were willing to shift their genome
enough to make themselves sweet enough
that we decided we really liked them and
we've planted them all over the planet
again and it's the same with animals
there's a few not a lot but a few that
we're like let's give it a try and it's
not you know us doing something horrible
to them or them doing something horrible
to us these are interdependent
relationships and everything in nature
is that kind of relationship that's
really my point I mean right we didn't
have plants all over the planet if it
wasn't for the insects that actually do
the pollinating they work together and
the insects get some sugar out of it and
plants get fertilized and when you know
when when that revolution happened in
nature when plants went ahead and
decided to try sexual dimorphism as a
reproductive strategy the world turned
green overnight I mean before it was
like in sort of creeping along at a
really slow pace and all of a sudden
you've got insects that fly and you've
got plants making flowers and the world
just blossoms like literally just turns
green very very quickly yeah so it works
but it's because they work together
everybody gets something out of the
arrangement and it's the same thing with
domesticated animals and humans you know
we get something out of it they get
something out of it and we all live
longer sure what's funny that you say
that you know you were talking about
about plants and sort of their their
process and I don't want to say motive
because it makes it sound like we're
watching a Disney film you know Fern
Gully or something someone's gonna come
in here and paint with colors of the
wind whatever that means but what I do
find fascinating this was an actual
conversation with a vegan he was talking
about how she hated meat and it was you
know it was cruel and then she just let
his don't want whatever's on your plate
cuz that's just dead my food is living
food and to me I was thinking you don't
see the irony that your food dehydrator
is the OSH Fitz of asparagus right okay
dad you're right it's dead and I was
actually picked up from the local
farmers market and I knew it lived a
good life I mean could one argue that if
you're gonna sort of create this moral
equivalency between animals and humans
which I don't believe it I don't believe
that animals are on the same playing
field as humans I believe we're smarter
I believe we have a space program and
like bowls so let's start with that
could you then is isn't it pretty easy
to then create the moral equivalency
between if we're all the same
why would plants deserve any any fewer
consider any less consideration than the
animals above them or humans well this
was the problem I had when I was a vegan
because I didn't want to make those
hierarchies and yet I was so meat eaters
would sort of taunt me with that
question about well what about the
plants and I never had a good answer
because I didn't want to be the person
that said well Adam you know animals
count but plants are just dead matter
they're just insensate salads and I'm
allowed to just help myself because I
didn't want to I didn't want to put
forward those kinds of hierarchies I
mean this really goes back to ancient
Greece and you know their belief was
that there's no sentience at all in
stone and then there's dirt on top of
that and that's not really alive either
and then
got plans and they're sort of alive but
not really and then you've got animals
and they're more like Gus so they sort
of count but then finally at the top
you've got humans
that's not how nature works in fact it's
a cycle and we all have play and if you
take one piece out of that cycle the
entire thing collapses if you destroy
the soil everybody dies
if you don't have enough predators
eating the ruminants they will turn the
place to desert you know every single
every single being in that cycle has a
role to play in terms of making life
more abundant and giving the entire
community more resilience so I don't
make a hierarchy I just say we all have
a role to play and we should do that
very gratefully because life is an
amazing thing but I'm an apex predator
that's the role that humans play just
like wolves just like bears and you know
our job is to do that well so well
especially if you're if you've got your
conceal and carry permit you were
predator you're gonna go a Jodie Foster
in that what was that movie Jared I
don't know it was basically death with
Death Wish with Jodie Foster where she
was often guys in a subway with the
brave one that was I hate you know what
I hate about those movies like I want to
get to the part where the killing bad
guys and I know people how dare you you
know all life is valuable as far as I'm
concerned you rape a woman you forfeit
your right to live I hate that I have to
go through Jeff Goldblum raping an
innocent lady so that I have to get to
Charles Bronson killing them and the
same thing with the brave one I hate
that I have to watch a guy get beaten up
just so I can watch Jodie Foster you
know kill them later and I like I like
the revenge part but they make those
scenes so brutal because you have to
hate the bad guy and I know I'm a bit of
a I'm too weak weak hearted to watch
that don't apologize you should you
should claim your heart it's a good
thing you feel horrible that we make
this admit entertainment I'm gonna push
this deep down inside nope no no no
thoughts that I'll never want to make
fun of me for it's that I know and I
know you're a feminist but I have to
sometimes let my man card show sometimes
there's no way if I tell my friends that
I can't I hate 300 I think 300 is the
worst film ever put to celluloid and I
know my man card deserves to be revoked
how many slow-mo decapitations can you
take I rather watch the wedding singer
I'm not even gonna lie anyway claim it
Steven klaymen klaymen
I said you know not a lot of pee
would think this I'm not an anti-war guy
I'm an anti-war 90% of the time guy
believe we should be slow to go to it I
believe we should be slow to be violent
I've never been in a street fight I
don't need to watch it
I don't need although I've watched you
know mixed martial arts we just had
Chael Sonnen on will have a George st.
Pierre on we have a very eclectic mix of
guests but I think a lot of people think
if you you know this if you eat meat you
love meat you have a concealed carry
that you're inherently a violent person
and it's it's just not true
you are walking proof of proof of that
layer so there was one more note that I
wanted to get into there but I don't
think we're gonna have time now so
people want to find you and read more
about your point of view your work where
should they go so it's actually really
easy it's just my name leer Keith calm
that's a joke because my name is really
strange right
so it's Li er if you can't remember that
honestly you can just type vegetarian
myth into Google I'm the only one with a
book by that name you will find my
website right away
so you'll see upcoming appearances all
my books you can write me email to you
on all that I don't read hate mail so
don't bother but if you really have
questions or you know you're intrigued
by some of this I can give you more
resources lots of good information I
mean we barely scratched the surface
obviously and you know a half an hour
interview but there's so much
information out there that I really want
people to have both for their health and
for the health of the planet yeah well
it is probably an even harder name to
spell or find if you're in a vegan diet
and you're not getting enough saturated
fat for your brains brain fog where is
it
clearly that doesn't leaf no she's like
leaves
I can imagine I will say a lot of fat
has definitely helped my brain so very
nice stuff leer and we appreciate it and
even though we disagree on a lot I
always like finding common ground and
hey it's nothing else right you are a
feminist environmentalist but we both
like a good steak and we certainly don't
disagree on as much as I did with the
previous guests an actual terrorist who
openly called for my death so there's
that oh boy you know I would never call
for your death so well thank you very
much but if i invade your house or great
pyrenees we'll probably take care of
that for me that's what she's for
they don't take prisoners it's like
you're done yeah yeah I know well ninety
pounds actually I would have thought
Great Pyrenees with a little little bit
bigger than that usually well she's a
girl the boys are a hundred and twenty
yes so the girls to top out at about
ninety but they're they're not
aggressive but they're very protective
so
right you know they don't start the
fight but they will finish it you know
if somebody is being aggressive toward
me she's on it well no but if it's not
coming toward me she isn't she's like
you people are crazy what are you doing
over there she won't just run and start
something it's more you know if you're
coming at me she just turns instantly
from you know ninety pounds of fluff
into ninety pounds of Fang man I could I
could talk about dogs all day and then
her audience will shut off the dial
they're not talking about policy
although I just nailed hopper so I you
know he sneaks up on me and I was just
taking a sock off you know he'd take the
sock off it gets stuck so there's that
momentum and it flung and I hit him in
the head so hard and I felt so bad and
he was fine he came up in he licked me
and he thought it was he thought I was
like gonna wrestle with him so he wanted
to start wrestling and growing yeah but
I felt I felt so bad man up Jarrod here
as a producer he heard it was like but
that's it with those great pyrenees they
are durable dogs and they love the
rough-and-tumble they're very noble
they are very noble okay very smart we
have to let you go the vegetarian myth
Leah Keith thank you so much we hope to
have you back sometime thank you
subscribe is what I would tell you if I
knew that you liked this video but since
this is the Internet and I have low self
confidence please love me